hi
i'm ryan wright and i am jerry welcome
to reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and maybe
not to see
now you see me now look closer because
the closer you look
the more we'll hang out
quit now
expose them now and destroy them
whatever is about to fall
whatever this grand trick is
is really going to amaze
look closely
because the closer you think you are
the less you'll actually see
reason to see number one
the four horsemen
all right so you got jesse eisenberg
woody harrelson isla fisher davey franco
and you know what they uh they're a
great cast together yeah you know the
standout ones obviously because they got
the most screen time and them and the
most in the script was jesse eisenberg
and woody harrelson but isla fisher is
is good too she's hot damn oh [ __ ]
borax gets the boner and dave franco
what's up man i do magic i mean he gets
a really kick-ass fight scene though
like yeah yeah at first i was wondering
there's nothing special about this guy
then he starts kicking ass in one scene
and you're like oh all right there you
go there you go dave proud of you man
all the four horsemen these four
magicians have their own style and their
own you know niche of magic and they all
make sense as to why they brought them
all together and and they play off each
other really well yeah they're funny
together they're super charismatic
honestly i wish there was more in them
because this movie starts off with
just them there's no mark ruffalo and
then it takes a turn and it's mainly
mark ruffalo yeah but i thought the best
scenes were with these guys that's when
it was the most exciting the most fun
sometimes the best scenes were not them
doing magic or anything it was just them
talking to me in the same room together
what's fun is they they seem to know
that this movie is about the game and
you know the trick and everything and
they seem to just have a lot of fun with
these roles people are saying like
there's not much characterization here
but i thought they totally brought their
a game to these characters you know you
could you get the characters you know
them they they play them well it's it's
a fun cast to hang out with it's a heist
movie in a way yeah what the [ __ ] else
do you really ex when you watch ocean's
11 are you looking for like
crazy ass characterization no you just
want to see a cool cast come together
and do some cool [ __ ] and it's cool to
see lucious fox and alfred together
again reason to see number two
mark ruffalo
uh
i'm tired my buffalo is always getting
out of bed before he he shoots this is
the scene i just like to imagine that 10
minutes before every single scene he
just woke up from a nap but besides him
being tired constantly he is great in
this movie he really carries his film as
the lead role and he has a lot of
escalating emotions throughout it he has
the strongest performance in this film
and because he has to he he's required
yeah and what's interesting is normally
in a movie like this he that would be
the character that is not that
interesting yeah and he managed to make
that guy very interesting to watch
throughout he yeah wherever he was on
screen he was always fun to watch and
even the scenes between him and diane
kruger i thought were great you know i
thought the sexual tension that they had
going on was a little bit forced though
a little bit forced yes but i liked the
way they brought it about only because
it wasn't like it took place over enough
time yeah it was like it wasn't like oh
the very next scene they're like
but hey but regardless she's really good
too mark ruffalo is really good whole
cast top notch especially
common reason to see number three
the game of magic at first i thought the
magic was a little bit weird because i'm
like that that looks kind of fake looks
like total visual effects over time it
stops becoming bothersome and it's very
uh it's fun to watch all the magic stuff
is fun to watch it's like you believe
these guys are probably real magicians
or something like that you know yeah you
do real magic and stuff it's kind of
left to the audience to decide but once
you see how [ __ ] crazy this movie
gets
it's safe to say that some of them
probably have real magic skills yeah
well and the thing is like at first at
the beginning of the movie i was like
there's a lot of cg in this magic and
that's something that in magic movies
always kind of gets to me because the
whole point is is you know illusion and
stuff like that but once you get
acquainted with the fact that this movie
does have a certain quirky sort of
fantasy element to it yeah definitely
that's when that concern melted away
from me and i was able to enjoy it for
what it is yeah and uh this movie is
it's about the adventure it's about the
game that's being played you know it
does not beat around the bush yeah it
starts off and they're like bam here's
the four horsemen here's this character
this character this character this
character and here's the setup and then
adventure begin and it's about pulling
off a magic trick on a global scale and
it just doesn't stop from there yeah
just bam bam bam bam keeps going and
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
that's what i mean it's it's about the
adventure it's not so much about
character depth and all that stuff and
so people who are getting hung up on
that let it go just let it go wait let's
focus on the fun it's about having fun
the whole movie is one big magic trick
in a sense yes it's all like all the
principles of magic and illusion figure
heavily into the way the plot is
designed it's like if you're looking too
closely you're gonna miss stuff and so
it's like you think one person's a key
player but then it turns out that
they're just you know part of the
distraction and all that stuff and it's
really neat the way they arrange those
things one thing i'll say for myself is
like i appreciate it's a ridiculous
movie like it's very over the top
there's a certain element of fantasy and
everything has sort of a snappy attitude
and it ends up in a certain place that i
can see
some people being like uh that's dumb
for me though i like when movies go to
to places like that and just own what
they're doing it's just a fun
the heist movie with magic
yeah it's just that and enjoy the ride
split decisions
the final twist
okay so this is a spoiler um until you
see the spoiler word go away it it's
just basically it's just gonna be
spoiling you're gonna want to turn the
sound yeah turn the sound off or skip
past it to where it stops saying spoiler
okay so this final twist uh with mark
ruffalo uh being revealed as the guy who
really put this whole plan together and
everything like that i saw that coming
before mark ruffalo came on screen when
they were showing the guy in the jacket
for some reason i was like that looks
like mark ruffalo's in that jacket and
then when i was watching the film and
then every the way how it was all going
because i've seen other movies that kind
of pulled that twist off before when i
was seeing everything i was asking
myself okay so this is a magic movie
there's going to be a big reveal at the
end who's going to be the one person no
one is going to suspect and what i mean
by that is
not by the audience but the characters
in the movie who are they not going to
suspect mark ruffalo that's going to be
mark ruffalo and sure enough it was mark
ruffalo's and i predicted that very
early on so i thought they could have
been a little bit more clever with their
twist i i see what you're saying that
was the thing where i don't know the
movie worked on me and i didn't see it
coming i i just didn't and maybe i
should have it's like if you if you're
crunching the numbers while you're there
you can probably figure it out just by
the odds but um yeah to me you know i
was just there for the ride and when the
twist came along i wasn't expecting it
partly because throughout the movie they
do certain things where it's like is it
this guy or it could be that guy or why
is she here you know so i got caught up
in those things and that suspends see i
never believed any of that i was like oh
the second they point that out i'm like
oh it's not him ryan's consensus
fun magical heist is the reason to see
now you see me fun magical heist is the
reason to see now you see me yeah like i
said it's just about the game and having
fun and you know what just go along for
the ride jerry's consensus uh a really
fun cast and a fun magical adventure is
is really the reason to see this movie a
fun cast and a fun magical adventure is
the reason to see now you see me yeah i
mean it's just everything was a good
time i just enjoyed myself and it's all
over the top and you know like
everything's snappy and it's just a lot
of fun even its music is kind of quirky
and over the top yeah everything is it's
a lot of fun all right guys thanks for
checking out our review for now you see
me why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell us who is
your favorite magician we just want to
know or what is your favorite movie
about magic and if you want to check out
more episodes of reasons to see after
you're done with that click this link
right here and if you want to check out
my straight to the point review of now
you see me click the link right here and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time a new reviewer video
is out
subscribe whoa whoa where did this box
come from like magic
jesus christ you were looking too
closely you missed it god damn man it
was right next to me right next to me
yeah it's always the last place you look
wow look at it that's a fantastic box oh
no no i'm looking at the box that you
were looking way up there no the box
there it's a box that's right out of the
box yeah yeah the closer you subscribe
the more reviews you'll see
you